hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to absolute drift now I'm
gonna get right into this game hello my
child you are here to become a drifting
master am I is that a Zen way of being
drifting is the art of sliding sideways
let me give you some background to
drifting drifting was created in Japan
by a racecar driver who had too much
sake during lunchtime so he couldn't
drive in a straight line oh okay I I get
an alga understand becoming a drifting
master will require patience and
determination next time we see each
other you will be a drifting master now
go forth and hit walls I mean drift also
drink sake okay okay bye have a good one
I'm gonna be here let go okay alrighty
then next song cool what is so cool okay
ah there we go gently turn then
countersteer hip oh [ __ ] well I'm not
off to a good start
some methinks someone made this car to
be quite drifty and also paint a lot of
lines smash blocks do I have to I guess
oh okay oh that's so cool it's so pretty
it reminds me of Mirror's Edge but from
a top down and not Mirror's Edge in any
way Wow this car is way too slightly for
its own good
hi I'm not the one that's doing this am
I am I not boink boink okay I did it ow
my face let me go
clipping point I don't know what that
okay quell handbrake to close the
oh I wasn't using the handbrake Oh
whoops Oh Kate didn't mean to do gay
housing yeah yeah that's how that's
that's how I do baby okay wow this is so
cool
I'm actually not able to talk at all
because I'm just trying to I'm trying to
do this correctly wow this is so weird
I'm usually not good at driving games
and this is no exception I have no idea
what I'm doing there we go okay wow wow
wow wow wow I can't say anything except
for wow this is so weird
it's so cool to have one second that'll
do that'll be better that would be
better wait sorry hang on one second
once again hello hello hello hello hello
a low low low low hello hello hello
hello hello
okay okay that's a little better okay
that's a little better sorry my volume
was way off on my control so it's hard
to hear the music and myself at the same
time okay anyway drift track I'm not
ready for that
oh god I barely made it in that box oh
where am I now
was I not supposed to go down at okay
good I'm supposed to be able to okay
cool this isn't gonna be like action
Hank I'm not gonna be able to
countersteer more if you're spinning out
okay cool
I don't know I don't know what you want
from me here there we go oh yeah oh yeah
look too much too much bleep oh oh oh
who is a master not me of course
crap well there goes my combo oh this so
cool oh it's so cool
look at that oh that's so crazy
well this is it's like driving toy cars
but you know not if you're doing it you
got fudge sickles god damnit go the
right way stupid I know I was going the
wrong direction shut up
I know gosh mom well there we go that's
it that was a beauty that was a beauty
that was a beauty okay
good a little more yeah okay yeah yeah
oh oh oh that's a beaut oh that was a
beaut yes I don't know if that's good or
bad but I did it Oh feels so good the
music school too
oh wow 15% oh that wasn't good at all
okay all right then Oman I'm like
tickled to death it's so cool I'm just
gonna try it one more time because I
think I can do I can think I can do
better cuz it the trick is I gotta like
I you have to accelerate through your
drift or else you'll you know you'll
you'll die but you also have to count oh
crap okay you have to counter steer to
try to counteract the forces of you go
and totally bonkers out of control like
um I'm I was a countersteering as hard
as I could
alright oh my god oh [ __ ] Oh piss poop
god dammit well sorry oh no oh no I'm
doing worse than I did the first time
damnit okay oh [ __ ] got tits oh crap I'm
doing so much worse
god dammit it's the orientation the
orientation is messing me up it it's not
my fault okay here we go yeah yeah yeah
oh that was good
that's kiddy that's for you that's
beautiful oh that was B I still did
worse than last time okay I'll pick up
all that I learned in the next video not
video but in the next [ __ ] course oh
wow I'm having too much fun this is
really fun it was really fun
oh this is really fun okay wait what am
i doing what am I doing here
drift between containers I don't know if
I can I did it didn't I do it didn't I
do that I don't know what I did
okay well Oh jump over the I want to do
that
hang on I want to do that god damn it I
want to do that get out of my way I want
to do that damn it
fudging fudgesicles piece of poop god
damn it
friggin all right hang on wait han wait
yeah wait here we go here we go
here we go boy oh my god that's so cool
that's so cool
oh it's so cool oh it's so cool oh it's
so cool it's so cool oh it's so cool I
got nothing else to say it's so cool
it's so cool what is with me and like
driving is really I love I love like uh
I love rocket League to death oh man
damn it I'm so bad at this but it's so
cool I've got like a permanent smile
second buck god dammit piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
gun not gave me you've come up with
creative insult oh you piece of poo okay
I got you this time I got you Kobe here
we go go go go why was it going
backwards how doesn't make any sense
oh yeah oh yeah go go yeah yeah no oh
just like that just like that oh oh oh
it's so good oh I'm so on right now
except now I'm screwing up
but I'm so on right now oh look at that
oh look at that [ __ ] don't look at that
that wasn't as good yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah there we go there we go I'm
doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it mom
mom are you watching them doing it crap
damn it just ruined it okay Oh next song
come on come on come on come on come on
acaba come on come on there we go
oh so skilled oh that was less skilled
that was less so it was kind of skilled
for a little bit there but not as much
anymore I'm not getting like long drifts
you know I gotta like learn to trade off
on the handbrake between the guests [ __ ]
well I hit that
okay can I go please damn it got him oh
man I was doing so good in the beginning
why does it always happen I do so good
and then flip flappity flippers off to
the wall damn it I wish it wasn't so bad
at everything
Oh gone oh come on
bad god damn it [ __ ] god damn it I'm so
bad at it but it's so Oh
that was it oh come on my first lap I
did like 70,000 second I did seven I can
I can do better I can do better I know I
can do better I know I can do better
everybody here we go here we go here we
go
yes just like that oh not like that god
sludge [ __ ] a duck
oh just drift drift baby drift drift
okay
oh come on Oh with your piss in your
balls there we go there we go now I'm
getting it okay
I'm using actually quite a bit less
handbrake than I have like before I'm
kind of mainly just using like releasing
the throttle okay there we go
okay Oh ah come on son of a [ __ ]
there we go oh that's that's not pretty
that's that was less pretty god damn it
I thought I was doing so much better
than I was last time and yet here I am
sucking it up to the extreme aah get
another combo another combo wombo combo
wombo combo Oh
oh those good one oh this is the last
one I'm gonna do worse oh god I'm your
poop this game is awesome this game is
absolutely awesome okay
I'm gonna end this here this game is
flippin amazing I forget how much this
cost but it is amazing it's on Steam
right now fudgesicles god I'm so bad at
it but I want to get better I want to
get better that's the point I really
want to get better let's see like I
didn't meet I didn't push that kid screw
you get get get get thank you finish
with zero points and pretty sure that's
pretty common for me okay so that was
absolute drift absolute drift is
absolutely awesome the music school the
gameplay is cool it's addictive it's fun
it's really awesome like I hate to have
to reiterate this but I'm not being paid
to play this game in any way I'm not
being it's not not sponsored by absolute
drift this game is purely fun really
cool really stylish really innovative
well not even all that innovative it's
just top-down drifting but it's really
cool really fun I highly recommends game
let me know what you think of the
comments down below thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
ah
oh and shooting pieces of myself where
am I going oh I broke it I broke it I
broke it
I broke everything why did I break
everything